thank you all for naked we're gonna be
the number one media conglomerate in the
world the key here is act like a happy
family we're The Osbournes daddy [ __ ]
Warbucks okay good fine nobody here has
any glaring substance abuse issues that
almost brought down the company right
how are things between you and your dad
pretty good
it looks demented why is he so sure you
know how it was wonderful of you kids to
take over people would do well to
remember there's gonna be a new sheriff
in town
well he asked me to run the company I'm
kidding Am I
you should Hey your sisters just in for
the day just to observe observe what can
I suggest you look for some downtime dad
you okay
maybe you should set your alt I do what
I want
we are going after peers us trying to
bite the most respected name in news
we're gonna [ __ ] eat them up
delicious let's bag this elephant let's
bolas Turkey
welcome to our funny little house you
have an interesting family I have an
offer
watch where you people meltdown is the
most deeply satisfying activity and
planet Earth we aim to please everybody
stay in your lane
[Music]
security [ __ ] off this executive-level
business we're coming up to the
finishing line horse [ __ ] not your roll
and remember money wins here's to us
you
[Music]
you